>>> FLORIDA'S REPUBLICAN RON
DeSANTIS WITH A DECISIVE
REELECTION VICTORY OVER
DEMOCRATIC CHALLENGER CHARLIE
CRIST.
HE IS NOW ON A POTENTIAL
COLLISION COURSE WITH PRESIDENT
TRUMP IN A 2024 PRESIDENTIAL
PRIMARY AS THE NEW YORK POST
COVERED THIS MORNING THE
HEADLINE SAYS THE FUTURE.
MY COLLEAGUE ALISYN CAMEROTA IS
WITH OUR PANEL OF POLITICAL
EXPERTS.
>> ANDERSON, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
SO LET'S BRING IN OUR PANEL OF
CNN POLITICAL COMMENTATORS, WE
HAVE DR. ABDUL AL SAID, ALICE
STEWART, CHARLIE DENT AND KAREN
FINNEY.
GREAT TO BE WITH ALL OF US THIS
MORNING.
BEFORE WE GET YOUR BIGGEST
TAKEAWAYS LET'S TALK ABOUT THIS
I GUESS PRESIDENTIAL PROXY WAR
BETWEEN DeSANTIS AND DONALD
TRUMP.
YOUR THOUGHTS, CHARLIE.
>> WELL, IF DONALD TRUMP COULD
TAKE ONE WHACK RIGHT NOW HE
WOULD TAKE BACK HIS ENDORSEMENT
OF RON DeSANTIS OVER ADAM PUTNAM
IN THE 2018 FLORIDA
GUBERNATORIAL PRIMARY WHERE
PUTNAM WAS GOING TO WIN, VERY
POPULAR AG COMMISSIONER, FORMER
CONGRESSMAN AND TRUMP WENT IN
AND ENDORSED DeSANTIS.
YOU REPUBLICAN WHAT YOU SHOW.
NOW DeSANTIS HAS ASCENDED WITH
HIS OVERPOWERING VICTORY AND
TRUMP IS IN BAD SHAPE.
>> I WILL PUT MONEY IN ONE THING
THAT DONALD TRUMP WILL NOT TAKE
BACK AND THAT IS
DeSANCTIMONIOUS, THE NEW
NICKNAME HE HAS FOR DeSANTIS.
DeSANTIS IS DOING WELL IN TERMS
OF HIS PROSPECTS FOR 2024 FOR
SEVERAL REASONS, ONE, HE HAS
BEEN A PROVEN LEADER IN FLORIDA,
FINANCIALLY AS WELL AS --
>> AND DOES THAT TRANSLATE
NATIONALLY OR IS FLORIDA ITS OWN
BIO SPHERE?
>> IT DOES TRANSLATE, THIS GIVES
HIM SOMETHING TO TOUT AS HE IS
TRAVELING AROUND THE COUNTRY.
HE IS A PROVEN LEADER AND AS
WELL AS WHEN THE HURRICANE CAME
THROUGH.
HE IS A FREIGHT FUNDRAISER AND
HAS RISEN TO THE STATUS OF
RECEIVING A NICKNAME FROM DONALD
TRUMP.
WE SHOWED A STATIC POT POLL A
HEAD TO HEAD WITH HIM HIM AND
TRUMP, HE IS UP THERE WITH
TRUMP.
REAL CLEAR POLITICS HAS BEEN
TRACKING THIS FOR SEVERAL
MONTHS.
DONALD TRUMP IN THE LAST THREE
MONTHS HIS POLL NUMBERS IN TERMS
OF HEAD TO HEAD WITH DeSANTIS
HAVE GONE DOWN FIVE POINTS AND
DeSANTIS HAS GONE UP.
THAT IS NOT THE TREND THAT TRUMP
WANTS.
>> LET ME SHOW YOU EXIT POLLS
INTEREST LAST NIGHT, THESE ARE
FLORIDA VOTERS.
WANT TRUMP TO RUN FOR PRESIDENT
IN 2024, NO 65% VERSUS YES 33%.
WANT DeSANTIS TO RUN FOR
PRESIDENT IN 2024 NO 53% AND YES
45%.
THAT MAY BE BECAUSE FLORIDIANS
WANT HIM TO STAY AS THEIR
GOVERNOR.
YOUR THOUGHTS.
>> I THINK IF YOU LOOK, THOUGH,
ACROSS THE COUNTRY WHAT HAPPENED
LAST NIGHT IN TERMS OF AMERICANS
PUSHING BACK ON EXTREMISM,
PUSHING BACK ON A LOT OF THE
RHETORIC FRANKLY THAT WE'VE
HEARD FROM DeSANTIS AND
CANDIDATES LIKE HIM, HE IS
PROBABLY A FANTASTIC PRIMARY
REPUBLICAN PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE, I DO NOT THINK THAT
WOKE MESSAGE IS GOING TO WORK
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND I THINK
AMERICANS ARE SAYING WE DON'T
WANT EXTREMISM.
>> I ALSO WANT TO PICK UP ON THE
FACT THAT DeSANTIS MAY HAVE WON
IN FLORIDA BUT DONALD TRUMP LOST
AROUND THE COUNTRY.
THIS IS A RESOUNDING LOSS FOR
HIM.
HE WILL TRY TO SPIN IT, ARGUE
THAT TRUMP NEVER LOSES DESPITE
THE FACT THAT HE CLEARLY LOST IN
2020.
YOU HAVE TO LOOK ACROSS
DIFFERENT BALLOTS, WHETHER YOU
ARE TALKING ABOUT OZ IN
PENNSYLVANIA OR MASTRIANO OR
BOLDUC, THERE ARE SO MANY TRUMP
ENDORSED CANDIDATES THAT ARE --
EITHER HAVE LOST OR ARE LOOKING
TO BE A LOSER.
>> DID YOU HEAR WHAT DONALD
TRUMP SAID LAST NIGHT ABOUT HIS
ENDORSED CANDIDATES?
LET'S JUST PLAY THAT QUICKLY
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT HE WON OR
HE LOST.
>> I THINK IF THEY WIN I SHOULD
GET ALL THE CREDIT AND IF THEY
LOSE I SHOULD NOT BE BLAMED AT
A
ALL.
>> IN VINTAGE DONALD TRUMP.
>> HAVE YOU LEARNED ANYTHING
ABOUT LAST NIGHT?
YES, IT WAS A TERRIBLE NIGHT FOR
TRUMP BUT THE PARTY REALLY MUST
MODERATE IN TONE AND IN
SUBSTANCE.
>> IS THAT YOUR BIGGEST TAKE
AWAY FROM LAST NIGHT?
>> IT IS A TAKE AWAY, THE
ABORTION ISSUE CLEARLY A BIG
ISSUE, THE PARTY NEEDS TO
MODERATE ON THAT ISSUE, THEY ARE
ON THE WRONG SIDE BY A BIG
MARGIN ESPECIALLY WITH THE MOST
EXTREME LAWS.
IN TONE, THIS ELECTION DENIAL,
WHICH REPUBLICANS DID ALL RIGHT
LAST NIGHT?
PEOPLE LIKE TOM KAINE JR. IN NEW
JERSEY, VERY MAINSTREAM, VERY
MODERATE.
CERTAINLY NOT CRAZY.
HE'S A SENSIBLE GUY.
HE DID WELL.
PEOPLE LIKE THAT.
BUT THE DENIERS, THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE OUT ON THE EDGE, LAUREN
BOEBERT IS ON THE CUSP RIGHT
NOW, THESE ARE THE ONES WHO
STRUGGLED.
YOU NEED TO GET BACK TO MORE
MAINSTREAM ACCEPTABLE CANDIDATES
WHO DO NOT OFFEND THE PUBLIC.
>> KAREN, QUICKLY YOUR BIGGEST
SURPRISE OR TAKE AWAY?
>> I TOLD YOU I WAS GOING TO
GIVE YOU MY HAPPY DANCE.
LOOK, REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM, I AM
ON THE BOARD OF PRO CHOICE
AMERICA WE WERE TRACKING THIS
FOR TWO YEARS, EIGHT IN TEN
AMERICANS SUPPORT ROE v. WADE
AND I THINK WE SAW WHAT DID THE
DOBBS DECISION DO?
IT MOBILIZED PEOPLE TO GET OUT
AND VOTE, TO REGISTER FRANKLY.
WE SAW WOMEN TURNING OUT IN VERY
HIGH NUMBERS.
LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENED IN THAT
BALLOT INITIATIVE IN KENTUCKY
WHERE, YOU KNOW, THAT WENT DOWN,
WHERE WE SAW MICHIGAN FOLLOWING
IN SUIT OF KANSAS.
IT'S ABOUT FREEDOM.
THAT'S THE OTHER THING I THINK
REPUBLICANS DON'T UNDERSTAND.
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT THE MEDICAL
PROCEDURE, BUT YOU'RE TELLING
WOMEN YOU HAVE LESS RIGHTS AND
WE JUST WON'T STAND FOR THAT
ANYMORE EVER AGAIN.
>> GO AHEAD, ALICE.
>> I WAS THRILLED TO SEE THE
HUGE GEN Z TURNOUT.
WORKING WITH THE HARVARD YOUTH
POLL THEY HAVE BEEN TRACKING
THIS AND IN THE LAST ELECTION
GEN Z GOT INVOLVED BECAUSE THEY
WERE REALLY PBIG ON CLIMATE
CHANGE AND OTHER ISSUES.
WITH ABORTION THEY GOT MORE
INVOLVED.
THEY APPRECIATED SEEING THAT
THEIR INVOLVEMENT MAKES A
DIFFERENCE AND THEY WERE UP D
PLUS 23 WITH THE GEN Z
GENERATION, IT'S FASCINATING TO
SEE THEM GET ENGAGED, THEY WERE
VOTING FOR CLIMATE CHANGE, ON
ABORTION AND EVEN PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S REPAYING COLLEGE DEBT
WAS A BIG FACTOR IN GETTING THEM
OUT.
I'M THRILLED TO SEE THE YOUNG
GENERATION GET OUT.
>> ABDUL, YOUR BIGGEST TAKE
AWAY.
>> I WANT TO PICK UP AND SAY
DEMOCRACY WAS ON THE BALLOT AND
DEMOCRACY WON.
THE BEST WAY TO SAVE DEMOCRACY
IS MORE DEMOCRACY AND THAT I
THINK SHOULD BE HEARTENING TO A
LOT OF US.
YOU SAW SPLIT TICKET VOTING,
FOLKS WERE SAYING I LIKE A
LITTLE BIT OF THIS AND THAT AND
IT REMINDS US WE ARE NOT AS
POLARIZED AS A LOT OF THE
NARRATIVES SAY WE ARE.
I ALSO WANT TO SAY THAT A LOT OF
THE PRECONCEIVED NOTIONS OF WHAT
THE MIDDLE LOOKS LIKE, INGOT
BUSTED.
YOU LOOK AT JOHN FETTERMAN WHO
IS NOT SUPPOSED TO WIN STATEWIDE
IF A STATE LIKE PENNSYLVANIA WHO
IS CLEARLY A PROGRESSIVE,
CLEARLY BELIEVES IN MEDICARE FOR
ALL AND HE WON AND SO IT SAYS A
LOT ABOUT THE WAY THAT THE
NARRATIVE MIGHT NOT BE RIGHT AND
HE THINK WE HAVE TO SPEND A LOT
MORE TIME IN THE COMMUNITIES
WITH FOLKS WHO HAVE VERY NUANCED
DIVERSE OPINIONS THAT DON'T
ALWAYS FIT OUR NARRATIVES.